the morning paper delivered news of
Labour's northern nightmare a story of
how faithful voters like Barry Johnson
did the unthinkable
one reason brexit being gone on the last
free year and we're getting sick of it
your army and it's been gone on and on
and on and on not would you consider
voting conservative again or do you
think this is a one-off see what happens
in the end four five years see what
happens this is blithe Labor through and
through until the tide turned to Tory
here political loyalties have been
passed down from generation to
generation like a precious heirloom to
be treasured well now there has been a
break in that tradition and the question
is whether it is a glitch or is it a
sign of real change
Ronnie Campbell was MP here for 32 years
but stepped down before this election
Ronnie I'm interested what went wrong
with labour we ignored the people I
think we ignored the referendum what I'm
hearing on the doors know what I hear
what the people were seeing they're
saying we what we want we want to leave
Europe and you've ignored them so we're
going to ignore you and that's what
they've done
inefficient chip shop on the high street
more lifelong labour voters explained
themselves was it difficult night why
did you do it the Labour Party that
originated and went in trust roots
it doesn't exist and earlier the Valdez
I'm not as stupid as politicians think
they are now we can all see what Labour
represents now Jack Walker and Alec
right have never missed a vote until now
I wouldn't vote liver because I don't
like Corbin no that was the simple
reason and I wouldn't walk Tory because
I just got to we've got too many year
who've always voted but this time
couldn't bring themselves to vote that's
right no no I can't afford Tory why not
I'm the sort of a Mainer simple
last-minute
glides mining and shipbuilding past
always favored labour but it was brexit
that broke the bond here time will tell
whether labour will ever be welcomed
here again Nick Martin Sky News Blythe